VERY NONSWEDISH LOCKDOWN IS
CURRENTLY PARALYZING HER COUNTRY
AND IT SAYS A LOT.
WE WILL EXPLAIN IN A MINUTE.
BUT FOR US TONIGHT AND UPDATE ON
THE SIDE OF GENERAL MICHAEL
FLYNN.
LIKE SO MUCH ELSE IT HAS
HAPPENED RECENTLY IN AMERICA OUT
THE FLYNN STORY LAYS BARE THE
ARCHITECTURE OF CONTROL THAT HAS
BEEN PRESENT JUST BENEATH THE
SURFACE OF THIS COUNTRY FOR A
LONG TIME.
FOR REASONS WE STILL DON’T FULLY
UNDERSTAND, MICHAEL FLYNN DEEPLY
OFFENDED PERMANENT WASHINGTON
SOMEHOW SO THEY DESTROYED
DECIDED DESTROY THEM.
THEY TRAPPED HIM ON A COMPLETELY
PERJURY CHARGE.
WHEN HE RESISTED THEY THREATENED
TO HURT HIS SON UNTIL HE SIGNED
A CONFESSION.
IT SOUND LIKE SOMETHING THAT
HAPPENED IN CHINA, BUT IT
HAPPENED HERE IN OUR CAPITAL
CITY OF WASHINGTON.
WE’VE KNOWN THAT FOR A LONG
TIME.
BUT WE DIDN’T KNOW IS THAT THERE
WAS AN EXTENSIVE WRITTEN RECORD
THAT PROVES ALL OF THIS HAPPENED
AND IN FACT THE TRUTH IS WORSE
EVEN THEN WE GUESSED.
FBI AGENTS DECIDED TO CLOSE HER
INVESTIGATION INTO MICHAEL FLYNN
AND HIS TIES TO RUSSIA.
AFTER MUCH SEARCHING THEY FOUND
"NO DEROGATORY INFORMATION ABOUT
FLYNN.
SO IT WAS OVER AND HE WAS IN THE
CLEAR.
BUT IT WASN’T.
PETER STRZOK DEMANDED THAT THE
INVESTIGATION STAY OPEN UNTIL
THE BUREAU COULD INVENT A CRIME
AND CRUSH MICHAEL FLYNN.
IN THE END THAT’S WHAT HAPPENED.
THERE IS NOTHING WORSE THAN
THIS.
UNTIL THE SECRET POLICE OPERATE
IN THIRD WORLD DICTATORSHIPS AND
THAT’S EXACTLY HOW PETER STRZOK
OPERATED AND THEN HE LIED ABOUT
IT EXTENSIVELY.
LISTEN TO HIS GREASY
SELF-RIGHTEOUSNESS AND
CONGRESSIONAL TESTIMONY TWO
YEARS AGO.
>> NOT ONCE IN MY 26 YEARS OF
DEFENDING OUR NATION DID MY
PERSONAL OPINION IMPACT ANY
OFFICIAL ACTION I TOOK.
THIS IS TRUE FOR THE CLINTON
EMAIL INVESTIGATION, FOR THE
INVESTIGATION INTO RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE AND FOR EVERY OTHER
INVESTIGATION I WORKED ON.
IT IS NOT WHO I AM AND IT IS NOT
SOMETHING I WOULD EVER DO,
PERIOD.
I UNDERSTAND THAT MY SWORN
TESTIMONY WILL NOT BE ENOUGH FOR
SOME PEOPLE.
AFTER ALL, AMERICANS ARE
SKEPTICAL OF ANYTHING COMING OUT
OF WASHINGTON BUT THE FACT IS
AFTER MONTHS OF INVESTIGATION
THERE IS SIMPLY NO EVIDENCE OF
BIAS IN MY PROFESSIONAL ACTIONS.
>> Tucker: WHAT AN OLEAGINOUS
LIAR, HE SHOULD BE IN PRISON,
REALLY.
IF THEY TREATED THEIR OFFICIAL’S
THE WAY THEY TREATED THEIR
OPPONENTS HE SHOULD BE SERVING A
SENTENCE FOR EVERYTHING HE JUST
SAID.
PRETTY MUCH EVERYTHING HE SAID
IN CONGRESS WAS PERJURY.
INSTEAD THE FBI CONTINUE TO LET
PETER STRZOK METAL IN AMERICAN
POLITICS, AND OUR DEMOCRACY.
THE ONE THEY CLAIM THEY ARE
PROTECTING.
INSTEAD OF GROSSLY NEGLIGENT,
THE DISTINCTION WAS BETWEEN A
CRIME AND NOT A CRIME.
THEY LET HE LET THEM OFF THE
HOOK.
IN JANUARY OF 2017 IT WAS
PETER STRZOK WHO TOOK THE BOGUS
INVESTIGATION GOING.
HEY, HE WROTE TO A COLLEAGUE ON
JANUARY 4.
DON’T CLOSE A RAZOR.
IT WAS THE INTERNAL NAME FOR THE
MICHAEL FLYNN INVESTIGATION.
THAT VERY SAME DAY HE SENT OUT A
14 PAGE DOCUMENT ABOUT AN
OBSCURE LAW CALLED THE LOGAN
ACT.
THE LOGAN ACT HAS BEEN AROUND
FOR 200 YEARS AND IT BANS
PRIVATE CITIZENS FROM CONDUCTING
DIPLOMACY FOREIGN COUNTRY.
NO ONE IN AMERICAN HISTORY HAS
BEEN CONVICTED OF DEFILING THE
LOGAN ACT.
IN FACT THE LAW MAY BE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL BUT NONE OF
THAT MATTERED TO PETER STRZOK.
THE LOGAN ACT WAS THE WEAPON TO
BESTBASH MICHAEL FLYNN.
THAT SAME DAY HE TEXTED HIS
GIRLFRIEND "RAZOR STILL OPEN,
SERENDIPITOUSASERENDIPITOUSLY GO
AT THIS POINT IT WAS OVER FOR
MICHAEL FLYNN.
THE FBI ARRANGED AN INTERVIEW
BUT HAD NO IDEA WHAT WAS COMING.
FBI OFFICIALS PLOTTED TO "GET
HIM TO LIE SO WE CAN PROSECUTE
HIM OR GET HIM FIRED.
IT WORKED.
WHEN STATED THE FACT, THE FBI
HAD SPIED ON THAT PHONE CALL SO
HE KNEW.
FLYNN’S LIFE WAS OVER AND HIS
FAMILY WAS DESTROYED.
IN LATE 2018 AFTER HE HAD CASHED
IN ON HIS BOOK BRAGGING ABOUT
HIMSELF, FROM FBI DIRECTOR
JIM COMEY HE LAUGHED ABOUT HOW
EASY IT WAS TO SET FLYNN UP.
>> LOOK AT THIS WHITE HOUSE NOW
AND IT’S HARD TO IMAGINE TO FBI
AGENT SETTING UP IN THE SAME
ROOM.
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
>> I SET, CONSENT THEM.
SOMETHING I PROBABLY WOULDN’T
HAVE DONE OR WOULDN’T HAVE
GOTTEN AWAY WITH IN A VERY
ORGANIZED INVESTIGATION, A MORE
ORGANIZED ADMINISTRATION.
I THOUGHT IT’S EARLY ENOUGH,
LET’S JUST SENT A COUPLE OF GUYS
OVER.
AND SO WE PLACED A CALL TO FLYNN
AND SAID WE ARE SENDING A COUPLE
OF GUYS OVER.
I HOPE YOU WILL TALK TO THEM.
HE SAID, SURE.
NOBODY ELSE WAS THERE, THEY
INTERVIEWED HIM IN A CONFERENCE
ROOM AT THE WHITE HOUSE
SITUATION ROOM AND HE LIED TO
THEM AND THAT’S WHAT HE PLED
GUILTY TO.
>> WHAT DID HE THINK THEY WERE
COMING OVER THEREFOR?
>> I DON’T THINK HE KNEW, WE
DIDN’T TELL HIM.
>> Tucker: IT’S ALL PRETTY
FUNNY.
DESTROYING SOMEONE’S LIFE AND
DESTROYING HIS FAMILY BECAUSE
THEY ARE IN THE WAY OF THE POWER
YOU SEEK.
HE WOULD HAVE TO BE A DARK, COLD
PERSON TO CHUCKLE ABOUT
SOMETHING LIKE THAT AND
JIM COMEY CERTAINLY IS THE
DARKEST IN THE COLDEST.
WE WANT TO BE CLEAR AT THIS
POINT THAT WE ARE NOT PERSONALLY
CLOSE TO MICHAEL FLYNN, HE’S NOT
SOME SECRET FRIEND OF THE SHOW.
IT ISN’T ABOUT ONE MAN COMFORTS
ABOUT OUR COUNTRY.
YOU DON’T WANT TO LIVE IN A
SOCIETY WHERE THE MOST POWERFUL
AGENCY IN GOVERNMENT IMPRISONS
PEOPLE IT DOESN’T LIKE, THAT IS
HORRIFYING.
PEOPLE COME TO THIS COUNTRY TO
ESCAPE IT, AND IT CAN HAPPEN.